you
are my
fire the
one
desire the winner is never the best
dancer it's the person who puts the most
heart and emotion into it what is the
name of your best dance move dick
step yo dude the way you said that to me
from close
range yo I I we were just in prison
together for a
second that was some sort of prison dick
step I'd have been like I'm stepping
dude I'm stepping one word someone would
use to describe your dance style um
probably a
[Laughter]
regret Joel let me ask you what football
team are you a fan of I'm not really
sure but I think it's on the front of my
chest yeah yeah yeah yeah the Kansas
City
CH why do I have a feeling it's
somewhere on your tains too like I got
it
right for sure when you poop you're like
[Music]
jeez so tell me one name to describe
your dance style
magical opened up like a butterfly
didn't it Tommy you are a five dancer
dick stepp and Son of a be yeah you are
a
five who does a chaotic dick step yeah
yeah yeah all right yeah
oh oh
[__] I think we know what's
next you
are my
fire the
one
desire
believe when I
say I want it that
way
you
are my
[Music]
fire
desire when I
say I want it that
way all right there you go man there you
go Dominique let me tell you something I
like your chances
yeah regret whatever that is going to
look
like you
are my
fire the
one the
desire
believe when I
say I want it that
way
oh confidence switched it up
oh you
are my
fire the
one
Des when I
say I want it that
way
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah